Let's go through a couple of solutions to this programming quiz
where we're trying to get 100% branch coverage for an 8-bit adder.
And so they way I solved this is using exhaustive testing.
The insight is that 8-bit inputs characterize the full range of values from 0 to 255.
What I can do is write a function test_exhaustive which let's i loop over the range 0-255,
j loop over the range 0 to 255, and then define a my_add function
which is going to invoke the 8-bit adder with those inputs.
Then what we're going to do is print the output and assert that the result is equal
to the actual i + j output.
This goes a little bit beyond what I asked you to do for the quiz,
but it's a good idea to make sure that the code is right.
So, now this my_add function is kind of where the magic happens.
What my_add does is takes an integer a and splits that into the bits,
splits it into 8 bits that represent the same value as the integer,
do the same thing for b.
Then we're going to call the addEightBits function with the bits of a and the bits of b,
resulting in a set of bits representing the sum.
Then, we can glue those back into an integer
and that's going to be returned to check our assertion.
Let's look at the split and glue functions.
Split is pretty simple. It just takes an integer, and if n bit-wise and with 1 is true,
then the lower the bit must have been set, and so we'll return a true value
for the low order bit position.
Then we'll go to comparing with 2, 4, 8, 16, 32, 64, and 128.
Together these tests serve to split the input integer into a sequence of true and false values
that together represent that integer.
The glue function does exactly the opposite thing.
It takes a series of boolean values and glues them into an integer.
The way we do this is by keeping a running total.
If b 0--that is to say, if the low-order bit of the input is set, we increment a running total by 1.
If the next bit if set, we increment it by two.
If the third bit is set, we increment it by 4, then 8, 16, 32, 64, 128, and 256.
And so together, this let's us reconstruct an integer value from its set of bits.
So, when we call these things together, we can verify that the code actually implements an adder
and incidentally, because we're testing it on all possible values,
we're going to get full branch coverage. Let's just make sure that that's the case.
Okay, so we just ran the code. Now let's look at the coverage output.
Here we're looking at the coverage output, and what we can see is that of the 85 statements
present in the adder, all 85 of them are ran,
so none of them are missing, and there were 9 partially executed comparison statements.
That is to say 0 comparison statements, which only went one way.
If we look through the code we can see that indeed, the coverage tool believes that it's all covered.
So, now let's look at an alternative solution.
Instead of our exhaustive test, we could have written a much smaller test that gets 100% branch coverage.
This is based on the observation that it we look at the cascading series of tests
in the branch coverage, basically all that makers are whether the input bits are 0 or 1.
So, if we call the adder with all 0 bits, we call it with all 1 bits,
and then we need 1 more test case, we can get 100% branch coverage this way,
so let's just make sure that that's, indeed, the case.
I'm going to run the adder again. This time it's not printing out anything.
Let's go back to the webpage.
This time we have 81 statements, and they all ran, and we have 0 mission statements
and 0 partially executed statements.
So, as you can see, the coverage tool believes that just these three really simple test cases
were sufficient to get 100% branch coverage of our adder.